So we have some actual good news out of Israel
despite the fact that it may sort of take
a while until anything really comes of this.
And the news is that the longest serving prime
minister Benjamin Netanyahu has been indicted
on charges of fraud, bribery and breach of
trust.
Now, as many of you know, Netanyahu has been
a roadblock to any kind of serious peace possibilities
in Israel for a very long time and not only
the, the, the not the only roadblock and the
circumstances that present themselves there,
but a pretty massive one, particularly given
his alliances with some of the most extreme
right wing elements in the Israeli Knesset.
And he has now been indicted.
This is the first prosecution in Israel of
a sitting prime minister and politically things
in Israel are very hectic.
There have been two inconclusive elections,
maybe going to a third vote.
This has been going on for almost three years
with regard to possible charges against Netanyahu
and the charges.
Now finally, now the obvious question that
most people would ask is, well, what now does
he leave?
What happens next?
It's unclear.
This is widely uncharted territory for now.
He can remain prime minister if convicted,
he would have to step down, but it could be
three or even four years until a possible
conviction would happen.
And that doesn't even account for the possibility
of appeals.
So this really could be a very long time and
it's going to be more about financial, but
I'm sorry, uh, not financial pressure, although
maybe so give it given the level of corruption
he's allegedly involved in political pressure,
it may be more about political pressure, uh,
in terms of actually making change happen.
Netanyahu is apparently planning to stay for
the time being.
He's immediately using it very Trumpy and
language to describe the entire thing.
He's calling it a witch hunt.
He's calling it an attempted coup.
He wants the investigators investigated.
I mean, it's a carbon Crow, a carbon copy
of the rhetoric that we've seen Donald Trump
employ around investigations and allegations
into his misdeeds.
But then there are also some pressing practical
political questions.
Number one, Benjamin Netanyahu is a member
of the Likud party.
Does the Likud party lose confidence in Netanyahu
and say he has to go?
There are elements within the Likud party
that are saying we need a different leader,
but so far the official position of Likud
has been, they're standing by Benjamin Netanyahu.
What might the quickest way be to get Netanyahu
out?
Probably if Likud says they're picking a different
leader, which they could do at any time, but
again, right now it's not obvious that they're
going in that direction.
If Benjamin Netanyahu stays in power, it would
not be surprising that he would try to get
himself immunity through a congressional procedure
through the Israeli Knesset, but there is
no Knesset right now in the sense that Benjamin
Netanyahu has not been able to form a government
since the last election, so it is a complete
and total mess.
What we do know, what we can say for sure
is that Netanyahu has been a disastrous prime
minister from the point of view of moving
forward on peace and some kind of even steps
towards breaking the impasse of the Israeli
Palestinian conflict.
Now, every time I talk about this, if I don't
mention the both sides, somebody gets mad
at me.
There's no question that Hamas in Gaza has
also been a disgusting impediment to moving
forward, but no matter that we still have
to point out that Benjamin Netanyahu has no
credibility as an even potential arbiter of
peace and he has to go if we want a shot and
hopefully that will be precipitated by this.
Although we don't know.
I've said before, Benjamin Netanyahu is allied
with the most extreme religious right-wing
elements of the Israeli Knesset.
That is not a group that is likely to oversee
any serious advancements in breaking the Israeli
Palestinian conflict impasse there no credible
path to a lasting peace deal of any kind.
As long as Benjamin Netanyahu is not only
there, but again under indictment on these
charges.
Israeli politics is complex, it's unpredictable.
It's not obvious what the next step will be.
Again, a conviction on these charges is unlikely
to be the fastest way to get him out, since
it could take three to four years for an initial
conviction and then there can be appeals.
So this is going to be a long one.
The immediate news is of course good.
We have to understand that this will be a
very slow process which might in the immediate
change, very little or something could happen
like Likud saying Netanyahu's out, here's
our new leader, which might actually bring
change more quickly.
Uh, there is probably more to gain by trying
to seat a new government than trying to wait
around for a Benjamin Netanyahu conviction.
But some good news, although it's unclear
how quickly it will bring any change forward,
we'll follow it for sure.